breaking right now at four o'clock more
than a thousand republic service
employees are voting to go on strike if
their needs are not met in the coming
weeks contract negotiations are ongoing
between the company and the workers
union sasha lofta is joining us live in
our newsroom with what this could mean
for all of us sasha david members of the
teamsters 631 union say this vote should
send a message to republic services that
their members feel insulted and
disrespected
this centers around weeks of what the
teamsters are calling contentious
contract negotiations
if this strike happens it could mean a
disruption of trash services for the
airport major casinos and thousands of
homes and businesses
we reached out to republic services the
company responded with a statement that
reads in part
yesterday's vote was a formality often
pushed by unions as a way to put
pressure on an employer in reality the
threat of a strike puts more stress on
hard-working employees and their
families
although the collective bargaining
agreement between republic and the union
expires at the end of may republic is
willing to extend that agreement if
necessary to allow the parties to
complete negotiations
now more than 1200 members said they
will strike if their demands are not met
in the next three weeks as that contract
again expires on may 31st i did reach
out to teamsters 631 but was told their
principal officer will not be speaking
as he is in negotiations currently
kirsten